[Musique]
Alain chou pour les quelquesuns d'entre
vous qui sont pas encore familiers avec
l'organisation interne des services
spéciaux notamment les services spéciaux
français le service de renseignement de
sécurité est celui qui est chargé du
recueil du renseignement et de la mise
en des mesures actives à l'extérieur du
territoire national en matière de
contreciminalité de contre-espionnage de
contreprolifération et de
contre-terrorisme alors tout ça c'est
des activités tout à fait ludiques qui
se déroulent à l'étranger donc
évidemment dans l'illégalité la plus
absolue et dans le plus grand secret et
ça donne du monde une vision un peu
[Musique]
spécialisée
monsieur chou bonjour bonjour Je vous
interview aujourd'hui pour un site
internet qui s'appelle
Serview c'est un site internet qui donne
l'opportunité à des personnes qui sont
pas assez entendu de s'exprimer on
voudrait avoir votre point de vue sur la
sire la point de vue de votre qualité
d'expertise de terrain sur
l'actualité bien alors d'abord je
cherche pas spécialement à être à être
entendu je le suis je pense suffisamment
comme ça travers un certain nombre
d'articles de conférence j'ai
effectivement quelques idées un peu un
un peu considéré comme peu orthodoxe sur
la Syrie parce que je suis pas dans le
dans le mainstream ce qui veut pas dire
pour autant que je suis un soutien du du
régime en place que je connais bien
puisque mes premiers voyages en Syrie
datent de 1966 et que je me suis rendu
régulièrement pendant 40 ans et que j'ai
parfaitement conscience que le régime
syrien est un régime autoritaire brutal
et et assez peu démocratique euh le
simple la simple question que je me pose
et à laquelle je cherche des réponses
c'est de savoir si l'opposition et la
rébellion actuelle sont réellement
porteurs de valeurs démocratiques et et
et capable de mettre en
place système politique comparable au
nôtres au moins en matière de de de
liberté de droits de l'homme et pour
l'instant je ne je ne vois pas de signe
de de cette ouverture dans la rébellion
syrienne qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur le financement l'armement de la
rébellion syrienne alors sur le
financement de la rébellion syrienne euh
je crois que tout le monde sait sait
aujourd'hui à peu près ce qu'il en est
puisque euh les financiers eux-mêmes ne
se sont pas cachés euh de de ce qu'il
faisait le le l'émirat Qatar et l'Arabie
saoudite ont clairement revendiqué
assisté financièrement euh et
militairement la rébellion le le les
services spéciaux sudien le Géral
intelligence
Directorate reconnaît avoir été à
l'origine de la création de jatan nosra
le front de la victoire qui se
revendique lui-même de de de
l'organisation Al-Qaïda même si cette
organisation est devenue assez
évanescante mais le jtin Noser donc créé
par les souiens revendique clairement
son appartenance à la mouvement violente
islamique violente internationale elle a
d'ailleurs
été classée sur la liste des des
mouvements terroristes par
l'administration américaine qui a
entrepris récemment un certain nombre de
mesures contre contre contre cette
organisation qui reste quand même la
principale organisation d'opposition
armée au régime actuel qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire de la position de
la France sur le conflit syrien bah la
position de la France j'ai un peu de de
de mal mal à la suivre dans la mesure où
on l'a vu tout récemment à 15 jours
d'intervalle le président de la
République s'est proposé dans un premier
temps d'armer la rébellion syrienne même
si
euh même si la communauté internationale
s'y opposait pour ensuite 15 jours plus
tard dire qu'il n'allait pas armer cette
rébellion parce qu'il n'avait aucune
garantie de savoir où où allaient les
armes alors c'est une politique un peu
lvoyante donc je vois bien que elle
consiste évidemment fondamentalement à
soutenir soutenir la révolte et la
rébellion syrienne mais qui n'a pas
l'air de trop bien savoir à qui
s'adresser pour que ce soutien soit
efficace et débouche sur des réformes
démocratiques ou libérales quelle porte
de sortie pour ce conflit pour l'instant
j'en vois pas les les les ce conflit
dure depuis 2 ans ce qui témoigne du
fait que le pouvoir en place dispose
quand
même d'un soutien populaire parce qu'
aucune dictature ne disposant d'aucun
soutien populaire ne peut tenir 2 ans
face face à une rébellion armée
euh mais 2 ans de 2 ans de guerre civile
puisque c'est bien une guerre civile qui
s'agit on occasionné de telle
destruction à la fois de lappie
économique de la parie d'État que les
choses ne seront plus jamais comme avant
que ce pouvoir le pouvoir en place a
perdu beaucoup de sa
légitimité et de sa capacité euh sa
capacité de commandement de de de
d'administration de gouvernance que et
que pour l'instant les seules portes de
sortie qu'on VO sont soit le le la
prolongation sur le long terme d'une
guerre civile à la libanaise qui qui
verrait s'affronter les les communauté
ethnique et religieuse soit une
partition du pays en entité ethnique et
et religieuse différente entre les
alawites les Drus les ismaéliens les
chrétiens et les musulmans sunnites et
puis les Kurdes aussi qui commencent à
manifester comme en Irak des volontés
d'autonomie voire d'indépendance la
Russie la Chine bah la
Russie la Russie je crois que la
première motivation de la Russie dans
dans son soutien euh non pas à la Syrie
mais à l'ordre établi à l'ordre
international établi vient du fait que
les Français et les Anglais ont très
largement outrepassé le mandat qu'ils
avaient reçu de de l'Organisation des
Nations Unies en Libye où on a les
Français les Anglais avaient comme
mandat de protéger des populations
civiles euh d'une répression par l' par
armes lourd du gouvernement en place
mais qu'ils ont très largement
outrepassé ce mandat en armant la
rébellion en la reconnaissant
diplomatiquement en bombardant les
palais tout l'appareil d'État libien et
Infiné en faisant lycher le le dirigeant
libyen avec avec l'aide de leur système
de détection qui ont permis de le
localiser puis de le livrer au lychage
de la foule devant les télévisions alors
les ni les Russes ni les Chinois n'ont
envie que l'ONU se transforme en une
machine à donner les bons et les mauvais
points de gouvernance et et et permettre
à des coalition occidentale de de se
débarrasser militairement des régimes
qui leur plaisent pas voilà ça a été je
pense c'est la première raison pour
laquelle la Chine et la Russie freineent
des quatre pattes et opposent leur
véteau à un certain nombre de de
décision d'intervention internationale
en Syrie pour la Russie il y en a
d'autres c'est la protection des
minoritésorthodoxes je ne crois pas
beaucoup
euh au fait que la Russie serait motivée
par les ventes d'armes qu'elle a fait
Syrie car la Syrie n'a jamais payé les
armes que la Russie ne fournit ni par
des considérations stratégiques de port
en eau profonde qui en Méditerranée qui
une mer fermée n'a pas beaucoup de sens
la position des États-Unis dans la
position des États-Unis m apparu
fluctuante au cours des au cours des des
deux trois dernières années il est clair
qu'au départ les les États-Unis ont
commencé comme la France et et la
Grande-Bretagne à à soutenir la
rébellion syrienne et et avouer le le
régime syrien au gémonie et appelé à son
renversement et puis en s'apercevant
maintenant que euh le l'opposition
politique syrienne est extrêmement
instable marginalisé et n'a aucune
autorité sur l'appareil militaire en
s'apercevant que l'Armée syrienne libre
est totalement neutralisée par le parti
islamiste turc pour laisser la place
uniquement au mouvement islamique armé
se revendiquant du du djihadisme les
Américains commencent à se poser des
questions sur leur engagement et et et
même à entreprendre un un un certain
nombre action militaire contre ces
mouvements djihadistes à travers la
Jordanie Israël et cetera donc je je
sais pas très bien où va
l'administration Obama au cours de ce de
son second mandat il est clair que à la
fin du premier mandat d'Obama
l'administration américaine avec Hillary
Clinton comme comm chef du Département
d'État a soutenu la rébellion syrienne
ça me semble beaucoup moins évident
aujourd'hui et je pense que il faut
essayer de discerner dans les semaines
ou dans les mois qui viennent quelles
seront les options de de à la fois du
Département d'État et du département du
Pentagone vis-à-vis de de la rébellion
syrienne est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire un petit mot sur laffire ma laff ma
est une affaire de de je dirais de de
maintien de l'ordre et de politique
intérieure sur lequel je suis pas
réellement compétent pour parler moi je
considère que ma est beaucoup plus un
cas psychiatrique que queun cas de
terrorisme international je vois pas de
différence fondamentale
entre ude de Mera le le la dérive de
Mera et celle d'un monsieur comme Anders
breviic en Norvège ou d'un Timothy mveg
aux États-Unis le le type qui av fait
l'attentat de clom City je pense que
c'est c'est un cas psychiatrique c'est
comme Anders Brevi c'est c'est un
monsieur qui a eu besoin de rationaliser
ses délires ses délires de violence ses
délires de révolte et de rébellion et il
les a rationalisé en puisant dans son
fond culturel personnel qui est celui
des des flamboyances de la de de la
révolte djihadiste comme Anders Brevic
lui puisait dans le vieux fond nazi dans
le vieux fond nazi européen mais quand
quand des gens comme Claude guant ou
Bernard Squarcini parlent à propos de
Mera d'un loup solitaire je crois qu'ils
ont parfaitement raison on déplaise un
certain nombre de d'experts
autoproclamés des plateaux de télé ils
ont parfaitement raison c'est pas parce
que Mera a reçu le soutien de sa famille
l'aide d'un copain qui lui a prêté un
scooter volé et qui a déclenché
l'enthousiasme d'une cent d'abruti sur
Facebook que ça fait de lui euh un
membre à part entière d'une
internationale djihadiste violente qui
aurait un projet politique et des
projets spécifiques c'est un type qui a
agi seul il a fait de deux séjours je
crois assz cours en Afghanistan dont il
a été expulsé une première fois pour
pour défaut de passeport et dont il a dû
partir une deuxième fois pour des
raisons de santé il y a sûrement
rencontré des extrémistes religieux mais
vu la densité d'extrémistes religieux en
Afghanistan c'est pas étonnant qu'il en
a rencontré cela dit c'est pas sur leurs
instructions qu'il a agi pour se livrer
à des actes de violence en France qui ne
qui ne servent aucune cause le massacre
de
Boston le massacre de Boston on est on
est là dans la même configuration à mon
sens enfin sous réserve d'éléments à
fournir maintenant par l'enquête sur
Mera on en sait suffisamment il est
possible que en ce qui concerne Mera sa
dangerosité était sous-évaluée par les
service de de de sécurité intérieure
c'est possible que pour les deux jeunes
gens de Boston ce soit la même chose
mais sauf
à sauf à avoir des éléments nouveaux qui
les relieraient là aussi à une
Internationale révolutionnaire
djihadiste je pense qu'on est là aussi
dans des parcours individuels de de de
révolte de rébellion individuelles de
gens mal
inégré et qui ont qui rationalisent leur
besoin de violence par leur attachement
à une certaine forme de religion mais
qui ont agi de façon assez individuelle
un un dernier petit mot sur l'esprit
critique des médias qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire sur leur lecture leur
façon de présenter
l'information bon si vous je suppose que
vous voulez parler des médias français
qui ou même européens et américains oui
bon les médias américains ont un
problème c'est c'est une espèce de
grande ignorance du reste du
monde et et et une espèce d'arrogance
qui fait que pour eux l'Amérique est au
centre de tout et que quand quand un
péta
une pbelle qu part c'est forcment que
les américainsv ce qui pas toujours vrai
en ce qui concerne la France en
particulier ce que je constate beaucoup
en France c'est que nos médias en
particulier nos journaux mais aussi no
no nos médias
audiovisuels font beaucoup de de de
leçons de morale d'éditoriaux de
commentaires et et assez peu
d'information et en tout cas ignore
beaucoup l'histoire ignore beaucoup les
contextes les contextes sociaux les
contex culturel
et véhicu une espèce de forme de pensée
unique et de bienpensance qu' essayent
de conforter chaque jour en tirant tous
dans la même direction comme un ban de
poisson évolue tous dans la même
direction sans trop savoir laquelle
d'ailleurs parce qu'on sait jamais quel
est le pilote du ban de poisson voilà la
crédibilité de nos politiques avec les
conflits libiens syriens
égyptiens'estce vous en pensez bah je
crois que le le l'opinion publique se
trompe pas trop a troué nos faut jamais
se moquer de l'opinion publique même si
elle est basique elle voit quand même
bien les choses et on voit bien à quel
point
les l'opinion publique juge mal ou a du
mal à comprendre les options les options
politiques de nos différents
gouvernements qui soient de droite ou de
gauche je fais pas
de je fais pas de discrimination puisque
ils se sont tous enferrés dans les dans
les mêmes problèmqu que ce que je
constate en revanche c'est que surtout
nos options politiques font que la
politique française n'est plus crédible
nulle part dans la mesure
où on brûle ce qu'on a
adoré on on condamne à mort des gens
qu'on invitait 2 ans
avant soit soit défilé notre défilé de
14 juillet à la place d'honneur soit à
monter leur tente dans les jardins d'un
grand hôtel parisien pour ensuite appelé
à mettre leur tête au bout d'une pique
alors nos nos partenaires d'outre
Méditerranée si retrouve pas trop mais
je crois que l'opinion publique
française non plus s retrouve pas trop
et effectivement quand elle voit un
président de la
République changer d'opinion et d'avis
sur le le soutien à donné à la rébellion
syrienne en 15 jours alors qu'il s'est
rien produit de de de spectaculaire dans
dans cet espace de 15 jours nos
concitoyens ont sans doute du mal à
suivre un peu les méandres de notre
politique
extérieure un dernier mot un conseil
pour les jeunesses les jeunesses qui
pourraient vous regarder par Internet
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur dire par
rapport à leur esprit critique comment
endurcir travailler affuter leur esprit
critique j'ai un conseil à leur donner
apprenez l'histoire parce que ceux qui
la alors elle explique pas tout mais
ceux qui la connaissent pas sont
condamnés à la bégayer alors apprenez
l'histoire
et il y a pas de pensée magique il y a
pas de fou euh de les gens qui font
quelque chose c'est que ils ont besoin
de la faire par rapport à leur passé
culturel leur passé historique les
violence qu'ils ont subi ce qu'ils ont
fait subir à d'autres et si on connaît
pas tout ce passé on peut pas comprendre
le
[Musique]
présent